それに期待が叶えるつの方法を教えるんです
絶望 絶望に陥る必要はありません
これが仏教なんです あれ
叶えそうもない期待でしょ
叶える方法を教えるんです
ブッダに教えられたんだから
これは百パーセント成功するんです
人間 なんで希望が叶わないのかという
その人に文句言うんじゃなくて
世界が悪いんだから私は金持ちにならないんだよということでしょう
みんな言ってるのは 税金は取りすぎだから
いくら儲かっても意味がないんだよとか
人に文句言うんですね
ではなくて 自分自身が豊かになって長寿にならない
みんなに褒める人間にならない
死後天国に行けない 自分自身に何かあるんです
それ解決すればなれる
因果法則によって探すんだから確実なんです
曖昧じゃないんです そうかもしれませんとはないんです
そういうことをね あの
こんな夢は実現できそうもない稀有なものだから諦めたっていうことじゃなくて
じゃあやってやろうではないかという
この諦めやら負けることは仏教は認めないんですね
それは面白いことにつ見せているんです
覚えやすいでしょ 希望はつ
その希望を実現する方法もつありますよと
しかし そこでするとい智慧が必要なんです
なんでお釈迦様はそういうことを言うのかと
お釈迦様から精神の問題
人格の問題を語っているんです
精神の問題だよと これが
金はただの物質ですからね
精神の問題だ それでしっかりした人間を作るように
このつには後でこのことを思い出して入れたんですけど
あの商売して金も金持ちになりたければ
まず必要なのは資金でしょ
基本資金 この基本資金のところ
あんたこれ持ってないとダメだよと
基本資金っていうのはお金のことじゃなくて精神のことなんです
だから第一は確信という財産
財産ではなくて基本資金と書いた方が良かったと思いますけど
資本 え？資本 資本 あ 資本
資本だと書いた方が良かったと思いますけど
それが一番目はサッダーサンプダ
信とは何事にも自信を持つことです
自信を持って生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
自信があると結構うまくいくんです
と言っても なかなか自信を持てそうもないんですね
しかし 欲怒りで動揺している人には無駄な話です
我々には自信を持てない何かまた問題あるんですよ
欲があるわ 嫉妬があるわ
怯えがあるわ もう感情が激しいんですね
あまりも小さいんですね
人間として 人のことを嫉妬したりすると自信持てないんです
だから嫉妬怒り見知り捨てちゃって
明るく自信満々で生活しなくちゃいけないんです
それは仏教徒に対して語ったものだから
微妙に色が違います だからといって秘密にするわけじゃないんです
仏教徒以外の人にはあんまり実行できないとは思います
だから 第一 信 最下信者にブッダを徹底的に信じることを推奨しているのです
それで解決します 仏教徒ならならば簡単です
すごい自信に溢れた人間になることはとても簡単です
方法はお釈迦様を徹底的に信じてやる
お釈迦様に言われたものは断然的に正しいんだと
世界が何言おうとも ブッダの道をなと思ったら
その人の自信というのは
地球の全部人間が一つになって
この一つになっても全く揺らがないんです
もう誰にも負けないんです
それぐらいお釈迦様正しいんです
お釈迦様が教えたものはすべて完成して教えるんです
いわゆる なんていますか
漏れたものはないんです
言い忘れたことはまるっきりないんです
なので  2500年前に説いてるのに
今も同じ真理なんです
そこまでの偉大なる絶対的な智慧のある人
完成した智慧がある人
人格完成した人に言われることを無条件に信じておけば
もう完全安全なんです
人々は何言われたっても
俺はブッダが言ったことよりは優れてないんだからと
ああそう ああそう ああそうと受け入れられます
[笑い] でも私はこういうことをやりますよと
みんなあんたこんなことやったらとかね
大丈夫です 負けません
だからそれできるのかと
素直に 正直に まっしぐらにブッダの教えを正しいと
それが心に現れたらもう OK なんですよ
何でも成功する そんな難しいことでもないんです
だから仏教徒に限ってる
バカ信徒が何て言いますか
なんかあの高井さんがなんか変な言葉入れちゃったんですけど
何でしたっけ？え？なんとなくもう一つ言葉ありました
無損版とかなんとか 限定版
その限定版という単語を入れているのは
これは限定版なんです
他の人には無理なんで
例えば神様を絶対的に信じた人が仏教では
これからブッダを絶対的に
それってあんまり信頼できません
精神的な問題がある ブッダを信じるということは
すごい理性に基づいて考えて
理解して 納得して あ ブッダには間違いはないと
私はそれを見せるために皆様に挑戦したんです
5番目ありますか？という夢の中で
人間の夢の中で 5番目ないんです
それぐらいパーフェクトに語ることできるのは誰ですか？と
なんでそんな能力 ブッダにあるんですか？と
これは昇華した体なんですよ
悟りに達したんだからなんです
輪廻の苦しみを乗り越えたんだからなんです
嘘じゃないんだから 今も堂々と言えるのは
だったらお釈迦様が言う通りにやった方が何でもうまくいくんです
それで信仰の正しいやり方
サッダハニタタガタスボーディ
お釈迦様の悟りを信仰するんですね
悟ったのだ これは紛れもない事実であると
それで信仰の言葉は皆様知っています
イティピソ バラワラハン
サンマサンブッダ ヴィッジャチャーニャ
サンパンノ スグト ローカリドゥ
アヌッテーロ プリスダンマ
サーリプッタ サッダーデヴァ
マヌッサナム ブッダというお経文がありますね
その9つの特色は確実にブッダにあるんだ
これは紛れもない事実だ
こんな人物はいるのかと
ブッダ以外はと 私はその人の弟子であると
そのブッダにアドバイスを受けて
ブッダに導かれて生きているんだという
勇猛精進拙するある 安心感なんです
ブッダが味方になったら
もうどんな善人が他の人を教えたっても話にならないんです
そういうことでブッダの悟りを信仰することなんですね
釈尊の悟りと釈尊が小学者であることを信じる
それだけでも項目第一
何で資本？資本の一終わりです
そしてそれは心理学的な精神的なことで
確信あるということは
本当に頭がいいということなんですね
曖昧中途半端は消えるんですね
緊張したり どうかな どうかな
どうなるでしょうかね
緊張しちゃうと誤まかったりするんですよ
それなくなるんです 資本の二
道徳という財産 道徳ということで正直な人間かということなんですね
仏弟子は不殺生 不偸盗
不淫酒を守る 省略しています
五戒を守る人は自信を持って仕事をするんです
この五戒ですよ 道徳で言ったってのは
殺生しないこと 盗まないこと
邪な行為をしないこと
嘘を言わないこと 飲酒をやめること
で なんで信先に来たんですかというと
道徳を守ると まるっきり道徳の一片もない
俗世間にいる心汚れている人々はキャーキャーキャーキャー反発するんですね
小学生が大学教授に授業するような感じなんです
世の中は もう本当にえらい迷惑なんです
何の知識もなく 何の道徳もなく
全くだらしない くだらない人間のくせに
何か真面目なことなんかやろうとすると
言うわ言うわ反発するわ
これではダメですよ 認めませんよと
社会みんなやってるんだからあんたもやりなさいと
そういう話なんですね
だから私はブッダの道歩むんだからということがないと負けるんです
ブッダになれたことやってる
なんだこの人はと 相手が総理大臣であっても
なんでこの人は ブッダの前には当時の国王たちでも土下座していたのに
なにが効くもんか そんなこと
だから 例えばこの例えばではなくて
戒律を守る場合は みんなそれにガチャガチャガチャガチャいろんなこと言うんです
屁理屈もいいところ だから酒
酒飲まなくちゃ 酒飲まなくてダメで
あんた今酒飲んで酔っ払って愛想笑いの方がいいっていうことですかと
完璧な嘘つきの方がいいと思ってるんですかと
ではこれからあなたを騙しましょうと
会社の上の人がね あんた酒を飲まないんだったから
もうもうもう怖いでしょ
あれ言って はい わかりました
これから徹底的にやるそうです
そいつを騙しちゃえばどうですか？ぐちゃぐちゃ嘘を言ったりして
酒飲んでむちゃくちゃ上司を侮辱したりして
会社で暴れ回ったりとか
それに文句言ったら何言うんです？あんたでしょ
酒飲みなさいって だから全くもう屁理屈ばっかし
無責任でまた だからこういう世界で我々は生きてるんだから
無知の塊 人を不幸にしてやるぞということに徹底している人間の中で生きていなくちゃいけない
みんなもうみんなとにかく不幸にしてやるぞと
そればっかり考えてるんです
そういう社会で戒律を守るためには
ブッダを信仰するしかできないんです
だから信仰は一に来て
戒律は二なんです 商売などは問題なく進むんですよ
すごく落ち着いていて
英語では sober というんですけど
まとめな人間だったら
商売はうまくいくんです
信頼されるので資金集めることもできる
例えば新しい何か仕事を始めたい
お金がない で 資本は必要でしょうし
借りられます 貸してあげる側も何の問題なく貸してあげる
なぜならば この人は道徳の人間だから真面目に仕事をする
それは大丈夫 信頼できる
逃げて逃げたりはしません
金持って その人責任持ってる
だからとにかくお金借りたんだから返さなくちゃいけないということで
この人一生懸命頑張るでしょうと
そうなってくると 私も儲かるし
その人も成功するし いいんじゃないかと
金出す側も自信を持って金を出す
東京銀行のようにはなりません
笑い ただ傲慢だけで 頭が悪いだけで成功するわけじゃないんです
口がうるさいんだから
あれやれこれやれって言うと
みんな怯えて腰抜けだからやれやれになっても悪いことやる必要ないでしょうね
それでみんなの預金がなくなるんですね
あの銀行の  道徳的な人間だったら
資本を探すのはそんな難しくない
アジャイル人も騙されませんし
この信頼関係必要なんです
だからそれは道徳っていうことになるんです
足を引っ張る人 騙す人などがなくなるんです
時々我々にもいるんでしょうね
我々の足を引っ張ってしまって
もう仕事を辞める羽目になったとかね
騙されて大変金が損しまったとか
なくなったとか 結構そういうケース出てくるでしょう
かなりそういうケースあるんですね
もう被害を受けてからもう何言ったってももう遅いんですよ
二千万円も騙し取られたと
訴えたっても あのお金は返ってこないんですよ
騙った人はもうそれで罰を受けるかもしれませんだけど
そういう人々はもう全然一円も払えませんからね
有罪だとそれで終わり話は
だからお金取られた人にとってはもうどうすることもないんだよ
返してこないんです その人が払わない
政府は払わないでしょう
そういう問題は消えます
収入は安定するんですね
道徳的な人の場合は 酒を飲まないと仕事上困るという人は一生困っていることになる
[笑い]よく見てください
そういう人は一生困っているんです
ろくな人間じゃないんです
私にもそういう質問をよく受けますからね
まあ仏教を話す 仏教を話す
聞いてる方々は 学ぶ方々はやっぱりもう真面目に
じゃあ酒やめましょうとか思ったりする
で 私も聞いちゃうと本当にありがたいと思っちゃうし
そういう人々は確実に幸福になってほしいとも期待もする
希望もする しかし 言われる問題っていうのは
やっぱり会社の付き合いで酒飲まなかったら困るんだよと言われるんだと
よく見てください 言う人は一生困ってるんです
[笑い]逆に聞いてほしい
で あなたはね 酒飲んでるんだから何も困ることないの？仕事上うまくいってるんですか？結局仕事の問題
あなたと私は同じでしょうと
酒飲んだんだかって何もなってないでしょ？だから酒飲まなかったら困るんだ
あれやらなくちゃ困るんだ
裏金払わなくちゃ これ一生困ってるんですよね
全然安心してないんで
だからブッダに言われるのは道徳まみれになった
それで資本ができてるんだろうと
それで何の事なく金が入ってくるんです
どうところに言ったって
大雑把で言っちゃうと守れませんだからね
５つの項目ではっきりとコンパクトにしているんです
で 資本の三 チャールさんから与えるという採算
汗を流して労働して得た財産に対して
仏弟子は物惜しみ ケチの気持ちがなく
分かち合う精神で財布生活する
これパーリ語ではヴィガタマラマッジェーレナゼータサっていう
これは物惜しみ ケチは心の錆として見ているんです
それ精神的な問題 みんな金欲しい欲しいと思っちゃいますけど
あれ錆なんです 錆があると綺麗な色を塗れないんです
で これ法則わからないんだから
みんな金欲しいと思ったら入るんだけど
違います 金欲しいと思っちゃうと入らないのは法則なんです
みんなで分かち合う精神が生まれると
いくらでも入るんです
いい例を出します 私は 100万円欲しいと言っちゃうと
あれ この人ちょっと気をつけましょうと思っちゃうんです
なんか私にくれとは言ってないんだけど
はっきりそう言われるとなんとなくあげなくちゃまずいということになるんじゃないかなとかね
とは言ったってね  100万円も日本にはあげられないでしょうと
やっぱりこの人と付き合うのは少々遠慮しましょうということになるんです
逆にこう思ったらどうでしょうかと
例えばある人がね 私はこの間旅に出たところで
すごい田舎のところに行きましたと
田舎で学校で まあ子供たちは結構苦労して勉強しているんだと
で そちらはまあこういうなんとかなんとか作ってあげれば本当にみんな助かりますよ
村人も助かりますよ でも考えたら
これまあ東京だったら 500万
1,000万かかりますけど
これ村人たちはお互い協力してくれるんだから
100万あればできるんですけどと言っちゃうと
その人分かち合い気持ちで来てるんです
あ そうかそうか なるほど
じゃあ私も 1万円あげますと
他の人 じゃあ 10万円出しますよと
何のことなく 100万円するんですよ 88
100万円くださいと言っちゃうとくれないんです
あの 分かち合うところが出てくると
先に採算っていうのは問題ないんです
だから単純に金欲しいっていうことはとても危険な希望なんです
でお母さんたちは結構そういうやり方で金儲かっちゃいますよ
金が欲しいじゃなくて
子供をあの学校には入れたい
しかし 高い でもとにかく子供は学校に行かせたい
うちの子はまとも勉強するでしょうし
だからそれさせてあげないと本当に申し訳ないという
この貢献する気持ちです
先に来るの そうなってくると何のことなくお金が揃うんですよ
うまくいくんです だからパートでもしなくちゃというと
ちゃんと雇ってくれるんですよ
逆に私はやっぱりルイヴィトンのなんだらかんだら買いたいんだから
パート来れませんよ  別の人を見たら
やっぱりこの人の方がいいやと思っちゃうんです
だから自分の欲が先に出ると
これサビ サビ サビですから
もう収入が入らなくなるんです
だからこの精神状態 いつでもこの分かち合う気持ち
で いなくちゃいけない
何か収入入ったら あ これだったらあの人とこの人はまあこれ 3人でゴリゴリできるんだぞとかね
こういういいことできるんだよとかね
自分だけその利益を得るんじゃなくて
この恵みができるだけみんなに分けるようにと
その気持ち変えなくちゃいけないんです
そういう人ですよ 世の中で金持ちになるのは
だから社会はあのお陰で金があって良かったとか
学校を作ってくれたんだと
何とかしてやってくれたんだと
病院作ってくれたんだと
そういう人々には金が入るんです
その人々のところで仕事をする人々も
真面目に態度を持って仕事をするんです
うちの会社の何々の人の会社だよと
あちらであれやってあげたな
こちらでこれやってあげたな
こちらでこうやってあげたな
うちの社長だよと っていうことで
社員たちもえらいプライドを持って頑張って仕事をする
だからそれって心理学的な精神的な問題で
あの人間の間で輝かなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間の間で輝く人に 承認っていうのはちっぽけなことでも考える必要もないんです
だからこれが必要になるんです
分かち合う気持ち これ 3番目の資本なんです
ムッタチャーゴー パヤタパーニ
ボッサッガラト ヤーチャヨーゴー
ダーナサンバーガラト
お釈迦様はちょっと文章を長くして暗記できるようにということでね
まあ美しく言葉使ってます
だから同義語はたくさんあります
パーリ語では覚えやすいんですよ
ヴィガタリーチ ヴィガタマラマッチェーレーナティーサヴィハレティ
ムッタチャーゴー パヤタパーニ
ボッサッガラト ヤーチャヨーゴー
ダッキナ ダーナサンヴィバーゴラト
あまり訳できないんですけど
もうなんとかなんとかごまかして訳入れてます
ムッチャタ ムッチャチャ
ムッタチャーゴーっていうのはあげたい気持ちでいる
パヤタパーニっていうのは手を
はい どうぞとで手を出しているんです
ボッサッ・・・ボッサッガラトっていうのは
あげ あげて これは好きなんですね
で ヤーチャヨーゴーっていうのは頼みやすい
で 分けち合いが好むという
ほとんど同義語なんですね
もう楽しいんです みんなで仲良く分け合うことは
ケチじゃないんです ケチっていうのはもう寂ですからね
はい 4番目 ちょっと大変です 4
番目の資本は 智慧という財産
パンニャーサンパダ 一切の幸福の元になる原因
夢は 3つ 叶う方法 夢は 4つ
叶う方法も 4つ  4番目
パンニャー パンニャーさえあれば何でも叶います
智慧さえあれば これが説明は長くなるんです
まず お釈迦様がパンニャーはなんだらかんだらで言ったってわかるわけないんです
ないでしょうに パンニャー
智慧は誰にも ないものの説明だってもわからないでしょうね
だからあるものの説明をする
[笑い]それくらいお釈迦様は真剣なんです
はっきり理解して 実行して
もうむっちゃ夢が叶ってほしいんです
ただ金持ちになるだけではなくて
4つも叶ってほしいんです
だから ないものから説明する
無知な人の道 一 異常欲望
アビッジャーヴィサマローバビブーテーナガハティ
チェータサーヴィハラントの一部ですね
個人異常欲に抑えられた意思で生活すると
自分の生きる衝動が異常欲だったら
アキッチャンカロティキッチャンアパラーデーティ
してはいけないことをする
するべきことをさぼる
これ事実ですよ 異常な欲で心が乱れると
やってはいけないことだけやったりして
やらなくちゃいけないことはもうやらないんです
さぼっちゃうんです アキッチャンカラントーキッチャンアパラディントー
ヤッサーキャスカーキャダンサビ
なしてはならないことをなし
なすべきことを行わないと
その人の名誉と幸福は破滅になるわけです
やるべきことをやっていないと
もう幸福やら名誉があるわけないでしょう
財産も来るわけないでしょう
なんでこの人やるべきことをやっていないかというと
頭おかしくなっていたんです
異常な欲で 在家においては
欲は完全禁止 全面禁止かな
と言わない 在家の人は欲はあかん
全面禁止やとお釈迦様は言わないんです
成り立たないんです それは
非論理的な 病的な 異常欲をなくすことですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃるのは
この非論理的 非社会的
異常 病気 おかしい欲をやめなさい
家族を愛することとかね
もうごく一般的な常識的な欲には何の文句も言ってないんです
ちょっとこの欲がすぐちょこっと脱線して異常になるんですね
自分飼ってる犬をね まあもう愛情あるのは全然問題ないんですけど
これがちょこっと異常になっちゃうんですね
子供が死んでも泣かないんだけど
犬が死んだらかなりひどく泣くんですね
イギリスでもね 結構人殺したりいろんなひどいことがあるんだけど
あんまり誰もそんなに気にしないんです
しかし 犬でも犬を見たら蹴っ飛ばしたりしてはいけません
ちょっと足で蹴っただけでもどうなるかわかんない
大変親切な生命を愛する人間というのは腐るほどその時出てくるんです
牙を出して 人間の場合は全然もう
そういう異常なんです
病気なんです そういうことで
欲は論理的な欲ならね
まあ悪くはないんです
しかし そこはいつでも理性の範囲で閉じ込めておいて
理性を飛ばさないように飛ばさないようにと気をつけるだけで十分です
です 一応この世の中の精神病の原因ですね
まあ私は妄想で全ての精神病の原因を一言葉にまとめますけど
あの まあそれだったらいくつか出てきます
無知な人の道に異常な怒り
ビャーパーダービブーテーナガハティ
チェータサーヴィハラントアキッチャンカロティキッチャンアパラデーティ
異常な怒りに抑えられた意思で生活すると
行ってはならないことを行い
行うべきことは行わないので
名誉と幸福が破滅になる
異常な怒り 理由もなく心は怒り
憎しみで支配されていることです
これがある方々も まあ日本でもいないわけじゃないんですけど
仏教を学ぶとそれに気づく方々もいる
それで安心です 気づいたら自分がちょっと異常な怒りだと
朝から晩まで怒り怒っているんだと
何見ても怒りの目で見ているんだという
気づくことはありがたいんですよ
気づく 気づくともうどんどん治って治る
治っていきます で 理由があって怒ることと
理由がなく怒ることで随分違います
だから精神的にどうしても怒り
だから仲良くすることは難しい
いいことをしてあげたっても何か文句を言う
悪いことをしたらもう話にならないほど文句を言う
寝ている時でも怒りでも朝から晩までっていう
だから理由があって怒った場合は
これが理由がなくなったら消えるんです
在家生活では時々怒ることもあるんです
それは問題ないんです
子供が言うこと聞かなかったらやっぱり怒らないと
理由があって だから在家生活では時々怒ったり怒鳴ったりしないとうまくいかない時もあるんですが
この異常な怒りっていうのはもう大変な危険な精神病気になる原因なんです
無知な人の道  3と 4 省略していきます
ティーラミッドフーティーナガハティチェータサーヴィアランドという省略省略全部昏沈睡眠に抑えられた意思で生活すると
まあ昏沈睡眠というのはいつでもダルい気分で
いつでも寝たい気持ちで
あんまり体を動かさないで
まあ 1箇所に外に出たくないとかね
引きこもりがちでいることなんですね
明るく活発ではないんです
これも精神的な病気です
で そうなってくると当然やるべきことをやらないし
やってはいけないことをやっちゃうんです
ウッダッチェクックッチャービブーティーナガハティチェーサヴィアランド
情動と後悔に抑えられた意思で生活するということ
情動というのは興奮状態で混乱状態で落ち着かない状態
決して落ち着かない状態
後悔っていうのはまた怒りの別な顔なんですね
あれもできなかった これもできなかった
やっておけばよかったとか
勉強しておけばよかったとか
そればっかり考えて自分の仕事をしないんです
仕事がある場合 やっぱり前もって勉強しておいた方がした方が勉強しておいた方がよかったとか
そんなこと後悔して仕事しなさいと
だからまあそういう過去のことで後悔することは
もう精神的に病気 それそうなってくると仕事しないんですね
その人の名誉と幸福が破滅になるということね
はい この 5番目 で こちらに号が来ても数字が崩れたわけじゃないんです
これ 無知な人の道は号にしているんです
しかし  4番目の中のカテゴリなんです
これはいつでも号で終わるんです
ヴィチキッチャービブーティーナガハティチェーサヴィアランド
アキッチャンカロティキッチャンアパラデーティ
義に抑えられた意思で生活すると
行うべきことを行わず
行ってはならないことを行う
義ということ 疑い アキッチャン
カルントー キッチャン
アパラディントー ヤサーチャ
スカーチャ ダンセティ
そうなると その人の名誉と幸福が破滅するになる
5番目は疑い それをちょっと説明します
疑いとは何なのかと 理性のある人の疑ではありません
疑は二つあります 理性のある人を持っている疑
物事を鵜呑みにしないで確かめるまで調べるまで結論判断を保留にすることは正しいのです
それも疑のように見えますけど
あなた疑っているでしょうと
確かに疑っている なぜかというと
まだ調べてないんです
まだ確かめてないんです
だから はい その通りだと言わないんです
保留するんです だから理性のある人は
知識人はデータ調べるまで結論は保留にするんです
それもまあ英語で言えばダウトなんですけど
これは正しい リーズナブルダウトなんですね
それが良心 これは仏教を認める
悪い疑は知識 能力 理性の不足です
能力不足 理性不足 知識不足
だからまあどうかな 私はあんまりもうわからない
もう信じませんと言うんです
それは理性不足 能力不足
だから能力ないんだから疑うことは悪なんです
能力ある人を疑うことは良いことなんです
その人は調べるんだから
どうすれば良いのかとわからない状態なんですね
結構あるんじゃないんですかね
何かいろいろ世界で生きている場合はね
毎日毎日次から次に問題が起こるでしょうに
どうしようもさっぱりわからないという状態
それがキーなんです こんなどうすればいいかさっぱりわからない
そんな言ってる場合じゃないでしょ
早く仕事をしないと 次から次に問題が起こるでしょうに
だからすぐすぐ何とかしなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だからすぐ判断して行動を取らなくちゃいけないんですよ
疑いがあると どんどん延期になるんですね
態度が いくらたっても何もやってないという
それではもう成長発展というのは
思い出したのは小泉さんの改革なんですけど
例として もう随分時間経ってもいまだに改革したことはないんですけど
だからまあ 愚か者を言うことはみんなそういうことなんですね
あれだから これだから
こういう問題でやらないんですよ
仕事が だから それを疑と呼ぶんですね
それはすぐ責任の疑 これは仏教徒に仏教の信者さんに対して教えた特別バージョンだからね
疑の中でも仏説を疑うことは幸福の障害になる巨大な疑いなんです
世の中のことは疑うべきでしょうよ
全部嘘だからね 何のことなく嘘に決まっている
しかし ブッダの教えを信じませんといい加減なことを言うな
調べてみなさいということを我々は言いたいのです
冗談ででも信じませんと言うと大変危険なんです
逆に私ならこうするんですね
全然難しくてさっぱりわかりませんだけど
だから説明してくださいと頼まないでください
わかりません しかし ブッダに説かれたんだから
これは事実には変わりはないんです
本当のことなんですが
私はわかりません いう風にするんです
そのうち勉強して成長してわかるようになるだろうと
理解できない だから嘘を信じませんとか
それとても危険なんです
よく皆様方で引っかかるのは輪廻の問題で理解できる能力というのはみじかいと知ってますけど
これものすごくの智慧が発展しないと
今の思考パターンでは全く無理不可能
輪廻を理解すること だからはっきり言えば
実体で物で考えることではなくて
別な思考方法があるんです
だからそこに上達しないで
輪廻はちょっと信じませんとかね
そんなことうかつに言ってはいけません
で それはすごい疑になりまして
足かせになるんです だからブッダの教え
全部わかるわけないでしょうよ
自分にわかる範囲で理解すればいいんですが
ブッダは嘘を言わないんだから
完全たる真理で語るんだから
あなたにわからないものも真理なんです
あなたのへんとうりん good いい加減な科学思考で考えるでわからないのは当たり前ですよ
科学を乗り越えているんだから
ブッダは 望遠鏡を発見
発見する前に 宇宙は無限に星々で星団作ってギャラクシー作ってできてるんだとお釈迦様が教えたんだから
地球は平で上天国下地獄ってこんな話はしてないでしょうに
それだけでも十分でしょうに
現代人に なんで二千五百年前でそんなことわかったのか
空に無数の太陽があるんだよ
はっきり太陽という言葉を使って言ってるんです
当時ではもう最近までみんな思っていたのは太陽一個だけだという話でしょ
そういう人々いう宗教は信じて
宇宙に無数の太陽があるという人の話は信じませんと
もう話になりませんよ
それだったら そういうことで
仏教とは まあブッダの教えは
何であろうとも正しいということにしておくんです
でも骨に聞いたら あんたなんてことだという人
わかってもいい わかっていませんけど
[笑い]それは別ですよ
全部わかるわけないんです
しかし ブッダに説かれたものには偽りはないことだけは私ははっきりしています
本当の義は仏説をブッダの教え
法を疑うことなんです
はい それで今五つ説明しました
無知な人の精神状態 頭イカレてるんです
で 智慧って何なのかって次に説明しますので
ちょっと休憩を挟んで説明します